75
of americans live paycheck to paycheck i
actually heard during cover that that
went up to probably closer to 78
80 percent does not surprise me not you
know um
within a budget you know a budget pretty
much broken down is your income minus
your expenses right that's sort of the
definition of a budget
and so you know in my opinion everyone
has the same
three categories within their budget the
big three everyone has housing costs
transportation and food and beverage so
yeah and for a lot of okay you're
showing you're single for a lot of
families there's also healthcare
healthcare is your second largest budget
everyone has these three
everyone whether you're married single
you know up down left right old you know
young everyone has these three and then
obviously everyone has
health care and child care and
cell phone but everyone has these three
um
these days being that everyone has these
three you know
my whole thing is i don't i don't have a
car i haven't had a car for 10 years i
know we joke about that
i've been able to save and invest a lot
of money from
from not having that big not having that
big expense so in your opinion
uh you talked about living together you
know family
um just with those three big expenses in
mind what comes to mind what tips do you
have
on how to mitigate these expenses i
think that um
i think americans have kind of lost
their minds when it comes to
not not owning a car but having to have
the car so i mean
if it's an 84-month loan there's
something wrong
you're you're stretching yourself so
thin to get into that raptor
or whatever it's going to be so that you
can drive the car
the beamer whatever it is and you can
get the financing
you're like as long as i can borrow i'll
do it cars lose 50 of their value when
you drive them off the lot
new cars and people need to understand
that there's a utility
that you and that's how you approach
transportation you want to get from
point a to point b
that's not even when i leave point a i
just want to chill yeah but if i am
going to point b
i'll take an uber sure and i'm i was the
same way all the years that i lived in
new york
and i i buy my cars cash and
i own them for a decade and i have
extended warranties so that i make sure
that my maintenance costs are mitigated
but but i look at it as being something
that is a utility and not something that
makes my budget
where it's going to crack so housing yes
you can but but
just because you're mitigating your
housing expenses let's say you've got
three generations under one roof let's
say you've got a baby boomer
millennials making babies and the babies
that they make so three generations
underneath one roof
just because you buy yourself budgetary
wiggle room doesn't mean that you're
like i'm saving so much money now i can
go buy that car
time to ball out on my mercedes exactly
so you have to look at
everything as what function does it
perform the house keeps
it keeps a roof over your head the car
gets you from point a to point b
so get what you need what do you say to
the people that are like look
you only live once i want to have the
finer things in life i want to live in a
nice place i want to drive a nice car
sure but they're but what's their
retirement gonna be like okay
you're like you can have your experience
today if you want it but don't ever plan
on
leaving the workforce you're going to
work until the day you die if you never
have the capacity to say scary thought
you know you have half of a you know
this is my bernie sanders impression
when he was running the president he'd
say
do you understand that fifty percent of
all retirement oh my gosh you do that a
little bit
too well it's a little scary adam you're
scared retiring with no oh my god i feel
like we've got bernie sanders the room
i'm not cheering to bernie no i'm
cheering because you sound like him
percent of all retirees retire with no
money but that's true fifty percent of
retirees
what ten thousand baby boomers that's
true turn 65 every single day
millennials are now taking over baby
boomers as the largest generation u.s
history
we've now been through 2008 and
millennials have like what three
thousand dollars on average in savings
wow so you see what's happening with the
boomers
half of them you know flip a coin
whether they have money or don't in
retirement
and millennials are trending in the
wrong direction and that's like the
first generation
uh in us history to make less than your
parents yep so for the person out there
making 50 grand but they're driving a
mercedes and having the time of their
life
like you said their retirement ain't
looking pretty it's not and i think that
that one of the silver linings of this
pandemic
is that you've got millennials who it
was kind of a wake-up call they're like
i don't want to be in an elevator
and even even if it was a temporary
phenomenon once we're all vaccinated
we're not going to care about being in
in crowded elevators anymore but this
mass movement out of metro centers
this mass rush away from densely
populated
big cities that's leaving a lot of tall
apartment buildings that are going to be
have very shaky
loans behind them commercial real
estate's not a pretty picture right now
but this move out to the suburbs um you
know as long as they didn't buy more
house than they could afford
i think millennials may be
able to shift how they approach their
finances now
hopefully they're listening now that
they're homeowners plus i mean you know
if they're homeowners they're gonna have
kids if their kids are gonna be like
gee i've gotta i've gotta save for their
colleges
and so it'll it'll shift their way of
thinking
if they start to have kids all my
friends are starting to have kids now
all of them so that's like why i'm not
necessarily in a rush because i'm like
the uncle to all my boys we know you're
not nervous my sister's kids
but i'll get there soon and they're all
calling me like what what kind of
college savings plan do you recommend
prepaid to 5 29 what do you got i'm like
yeah but they were having the time of
their lives they were the experiential
buddies
two years ago this is more of a personal
question but you know maybe
recommendations of what you're seeing
your biggest financial regret or your
worst purchase or the biggest waste of
money
and if you had a mulligan what would you
do over
so when i left the fed i had like
ptsd serious i mean i was inside the
sausage factory
i'm watching the printing presses go 24
7. i'm horrified
at these academics that that are running
the biggest economy on
planet earth me who's like oh
i'm like walking talking hyperactivity
syndrome poster child i said
i took two and a half years of my life
and wrote a book i mean i've never had
that much focus in my life because i was
so upset about
what i saw so i went i was short the
market
now i wasn't short the market for a long
time but i lost money being short the
market because i'm like
i'll show them what you're those damn
money printers it was this was um
this was 10 2010. but you were shorting
the market in 2010
no no i'm sorry this was this was 2015.
sorry oh
2015. 2015. and i lost money
and i realized that i was doing one
thing and saying the other
i'm on my twitter feed saying all you
need to follow is
the liquidity as long as the fed is
pumping liquidity into the system
stocks will rise so i knew it and i'd
seen it
and i'd bore witness to it but i was so
pissed off at what they were doing to
the finances of the country
i wanted the stock market to fall you
can't look at it that way
it was like your emotions were taking
over logic yes exactly
well one thing i've learned from ceo
patrick david valuetainment
less emotion more logic oh gosh yes
people are always like you're bitter
you're short the market and i'm like
on my twitter feed and i'm like i am not
well what do you think would you not
short this what do you think with all
this you know game stop reddit
shorting hedge fund um you know
that is to me emblematic more
of the last time markets were looking
this frothy was like 2017.
by frothy over that term overvalued so
you know right right now we're in the
99th percentile of valuations on the
stock market going back to data from
1881
so i mean it's really it's it's very
speculative
but what we didn't have in 2017 because
in 2017
as as we ended the year jay powell was
getting ready to take over he talked
tough he freaked out the markets are
like oh my god the fed's not going to be
my sugar daddy anymore
he had valmageddon where volatility
spiked the first day he was in office
february the 4th
2019. my birthday ironically there you
go i remember that february so that then
you know when his
term ends is next february the 4th 20th
22 best birthday present i could ever
have
unless they replaced him with somebody
more dovish my gosh
but there was the powell pivot and he
was like i was kidding
okay fine i'll give i'll give the
pacifier back to the baby
and liquidity started flowing back into
the markets
and stocks pop back up so
2019 was more of a scare
in the markets and then the fed just
went pedal to the metal and started
printing a ton of money and here we are
today
the difference between 2017 coming out
of it when stocks were overvalued and we
knew they were and today
is the retail investor we didn't have
retail participation
a few years ago at the level it is now
now it's a fifth
of volume and they're buying calls
they're not even buying the underlying
stocks
so they're juicing volumes they're
juicing liquidity
everybody talks about you know bitty and
gamestop and amc and what's being
shorted next
let's squeeze the hell out of it these
are just signs of
i mean people don't like to hear this
but the smart money
typically exits stage left
when retail goes over a certain
percentage of trading because they
always say the dumb money comes in last
at the end of a cycle so i look at
the short sellers and read it and the
chat boards and robin hood
and the proliferation i mean you could
how many uber drivers are probably
talking about bitcoin today
oh it's the talk of the town okay so but
when you get there the smart money is
typically already gone
so what's your advice final piece of
advice with that segment
uh you better be if if you're a nimble
trader
and you want to play these things just
understand that you're playing them
you're not investing in them this isn't
long-term investment no no no no
this is this is trading this is this is
trading it is gambling it is pure
gambling
there is a reason that robin hood is
structured such that it feels like two
young men
that they're playing video games that
was how robin hood was designed it was
designed to appeal
to the endorphins you get when you play
video games
and that's exactly the people who are on
it
and some of them are going to lose their
ass and some of them are going to lose
some of them did lose their ass
on gamestop that's right thank you for
watching this short clip if you want to
see the full
episode check it out right here and if
you have not subscribed to valuetainment
click right here
[Music]
all we talk is money